[Music]
Whatever, there's no
firewood, but there's a fire Magic
potions and magic Finally, a mallet and a magic
furnace
Please don't say anything strange.
Of course it's cooked all the time
[Music] It's
got a strong flavor and depth To be honest, it's much tastier than the food at the mansion
[Music] All right, all right.
It's a dish
Eh, what is the
fish? No, it's
nothing.  I don't know, but I tried not to worry about all the
dishes like they came out of that pot, but it's
probably okay. It's roast
beef.
Dessert ice cream
[music]
[applause] [
music]
Warm drink
to finish Amazake (sweet sake) Are you
satisfied?
All the hot pot was
delicious Thank you very much for the meal